I know hello lovely to meet you
congratulations on your new Bath & Body
range what's the best thing about having
your own Beauty range I think the best
thing about having my own Beauty range
is having the freedom to create
something that I absolutely love so it
could be anything any color any scent I
think that's the most exciting thing
definitely I like the lip balm what's
your favorite products on the range
might well have all of them but I would
have to say my favorite is probably the
scrub because I really wanted something
that was quite summery and I also loved
the texture and I love how it makes my
skin feel what's your all-time favorite
makeup look oh I think my all-time
favorite is either a smoky gold eye or I
really like a red lip or a berry diff
actually I'm going to talk to you a bit
about your home life now okay what's it
like having your puppy Nala around the
house it is chaotic as you can see she's
quite an excited player she's running
around in the background because she's
only ten months old she does require a
lot of attention but I love her a lot
and it would be really strange if she
wasn't around because it's like that
little excited we call it a bullet
because she's so quick and wherever you
are she wants to be with you but it is
so lovely it's like having a constant
little friend
which is very nice what advice would you
give someone who's thinking of getting a
puppy I have a lot of advice for someone
who's thinking of getting a puppy only
because I had never had a dog before we
had Nala not in our family or ever so it
was quite a shock to the system getting
a puppy but I would say the biggest
advice is going to puppy classes because
you learn so much and the trainer's are
great and it's a really good way of
being around other people who have also
just got puppies because it can be quite
a shock to the system and it's just so
so much fun for her to interact with
other puppies and yeah I think that
would be my main piece of advice is go
to puppy classes straight away
what's your favorite place to shop for
nice things in your house oh I like this
question I like a lot of things in John
Lewis Tiger have some lovely little home
bit next home I've got some nice things
in there I basically just have
everything copper and fairy light
because I think very like to make
everything that's so cute
what's your favorite favorite Oh
my favorite favorite dinner would either
be a pizza do you like pizza what's your
favorite pizza pepperoni all I think
pizza or something with mashed potatoes
and obsessed with mashed potato I think
I could eat it with anything which is a
bit weird but I like it
Lucas what's your favorite movie I like
all the Disney films you've got a
favorite Disney film area or The Little
Mermaid
I have a big one I like all the Disney
films and I also like the miserab I
think that's a really good film now I
think this sounds important cool it's
about your vlogging
oh yeah why did you first start your
YouTube channel I first started my
youtube channel because I was watching a
lot of other people do YouTube and I was
gaining a lot of really useful tips from
other people and then I felt very
passionate about makeup and beauty and
because I was too shy to make youtube I
started vlogging and then once I felt
confident blogging I then
all right back in Joe's video some
people might want to watch it and then
from there I absolutely loved it and
just carried on what's being the best
bit so far since you launched your
channel all that's a hard question
there's so many best bit I think one of
the greatest things that's come out of
starting the channel is making so many
amazing friends who I've now got for
life and meeting LC and Louise and just
having lots of really amazing
opportunities who would you like to do a
chap a challenge with oh he would I like
to do a challenge with I think I would
love to do a challenge with Taylor Swift
don't know what the challenge would be
but I think it would be quite fun she's
frightfully a very fun person to be
around what's being your favorite
challenge so far I think one of my
favourite challenges which is actually
the most viewed video on my youtube
channel is the seven second challenge
with Miranda sings it always makes me
laugh if I'm having like a bit of a down
day I'll put the video on and it's
guaranteed to make me smile by the end
and I feel like a lot of people feel
that way about the video so I think that
one are you excited about having your
wax work in Madame Tussauds I am very
excited it's going to be very strange
because I was Saint Alfie you never
really see yourself in full 3d when you
look in the mirror you can kind of you
can get about this much but you've never
seen yourself all the way around so it's
going to be really weird to like walk
around the waxwork and just be like oh
that's what I really look like yeah it's
gonna be really really exciting but
really strange I feel like what advice
would you give me if I wanted to be a
vlogger I would say to have fun that's
the main thing because if you're not
enjoying it then people will be able to
tell when they watch your videos and if
you're really passionate about what
you're talking about and you're happy
and you're having a good time that I
think everyone will be instantly drawn
to watching the videos
don't worry about not feeling confident
at first because if you go back and
watch everyone else's first videos
they're never super amazing or they're
not really confident it's kind of
something that you learn and kind of
progress with as you go and good
lighting is always key always sit by a
window thank you for answering all my
questions I don't wanna hurt you enjoyed
them thank you I did thank you very much
done great interviewer